[Musique]
eva longoria
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
vous allez faire le rêve de ma vie vous
allez venir m'invite à danser you're
going to him va être mis tout dancing
yes
damas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ballon
ah
voir qu'à plusieurs galas 1 voilà donc
et va en fait neuf exactement il ya neuf
gars là nos fous qu'à la
voilà donc qui va
une fois de temps en temps je vais vous
dire un bon français on part si ça tombe
bien moi aussi une fois qu'on a dans le
garage mon anglais
nommé
tous les très basses eaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
eva je suis pas venu pour ça d'habitude
je fais shabbat acheteurs cibles
je te le dis je suis pas venu pour ça
mais il ya vraiment un amour chinois
tués franchement tu sais que pour moi tu
es la plus belle femme du monde et je
vis vraiment c
[Musique]
et bien voilà
là on peut dire que ce sont des l'île
ronde et d'agglo et en plus comme par
hasard ils parlent un tout petit peu
mieux en anglais quand elle l a
fait des efforts il faisait partie il
ferait un très joli couple
n'hésite pas d'ailleurs ce pardon et aux
deux époques les deux extraits qu'on a
vus ils sont beaux tous les deux ils ont
une bonne évolution est la nazisme et
merci merci
la première édition il a fait croire que
va me demander mon numéro de téléphone
est actuellement j'avais reçu des faux
sms en disant qu'elle me donnait
rendez-vous le lendemain matin les
records du congé
non ma valise j'ai hésité toute la nuit
j'appelle tous mes potes de givet ou pas
et me faire vraiment les charges wayne
dans son jet pour aller à cannes et
après à los angeles il faudrait vraiment
comme une vanille qu'eva longoria vous
envoyez des nues mais non mais vraiment
pas plus qu'un autre vous avez du visage
séduisant